4 vos deux journalistes hervé ghesquière
et stéphane taponier sont toujours
retenus en afghanistan
nous sommes tous extrêmement solidaires
bien sûr de france télévisions et des
familles et de cette situation je sais
que le débat a eu lieu au sein des
différentes instances de fond cette
vision mais est ce que vous ne pensez
pas qu en le rappelant tous les jours
qui est certes un signal d'affection et
de soutien
est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'on
amplifie qu'on rend plus difficile la
négociation avec des gens qui les
retiennent et qui ne demande qu'une
chose c'est de faire monter la valeur
dans l'opinion publique
je reprends peut-être dans l'ordre si
vous mieux autorisée
concernant l'organisation deux points le
premier c'est que évidemment nous ne
reviendrons pas sur la mise en commun
des services supports cire que tout ce
qui est service support ressources
humaines finance informatique technique
etc doit bien sûr rester les services
supports de france télévisions au
service des chaînes il ne s'agit donc
pas de recréer les chaînes telles
qu'elles existaient chacune ayant ses
services supports pour autant je
voudrais indiquer que ce travail est un
travail en cours et que nous devons
finaliser puisque par exemple systèmes
d'information sont encore différent nous
avons encore quatre systèmes
d'information de paye donc il ya un
travail à faire et ça c'est un axe très
précis tous les services supports
doivent se réunifier pour permettre
d'être plus efficace au service des
chaînes concernant la deuxième
le deuxième point qui est le rapport
entre les programmes et les antennes que
vous avez posé comme seul e à poser
aussi
nous sommes en plein débat et et ce
débat nous allons trancher je
l'indiquais rapidement dans mon exposé
tout à l'heure dès les prochains jours
enfin je souhaite qu'il soit tranché
avant avant mi-octobre avait avec souley
de deux points le premier c'est que il
faut redonner une identité aux chaînes
donc la capacité de décider des
programmes et donc ça répond à la
question du guichet unique
lorsque vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la
manière dont les producteurs ou les
créateurs 10
la question du choix se pose je lis dans
votre question le débat sur le guichet
unique et le fait qu' on dit à tort ou à
raison que c'est une seule personne qui
décide de tout les fictions de tous les
documentaires
donc on a bien deux questions qui se
posent à nous la première c'est
l'identité des chaînes et la
dynamisation des programmes de chaque
chaîne avec une cohérence avec versus la
nécessité absolue d'avoir une parfaite
coordination pour ne pas faire deux fois
la même chose avec la notion de
d'innovation qui est très forte dans le
projet et on sait que l'innovation et de
insufflé par quelque part quelque chose
qui s'appelle la recherche développement
et qui doit être nécessairement
centraliser parce qu'on a pas multiples
et de recherche développement
donc c'est cette question de
l'articulation à l'intérieur de france
télévisions de l'identité des chaînes
indispensable et en même temps d'une
forte coordination et d'une capacité à
vraiment piloter l'ensemble qui se pose
et il faut le faire avec des règles très
simples qui soit compréhensible et deux
internes et de l'externe pour éviter
tout ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
alors c'est le devoir sur lequel nous
planchons actuellement et est et qui est
notamment une des questions qu'on va
aborder lors d'un séminaire en fin de
semaine sur la déontologie
nous démarrons en réalité la réflexion
puisque c'est un travail que j'ai
demandé à thierry thulliez ces derniers
ces derniers jours nous souhaitons que
la charte de déontologie soit intégré
l'année c'est à la négociation du
contrat collectif avec les journalistes
c'est dire que ont renégocié les
contrats d'entreprise sur les
journalistes et on souhaite intégrer
cette réflexion sur la charte de
déontologie de là dedans pour répondre à
votre question
d'ailleurs pour dire que un journaliste
à france télévisions il a un rôle qui
pour nous est essentiel puisque la
mission d'information de france
télévisions était essentielle et que
nous souhaitons absolument définir
ensemble et dans le cadre d'une
négociation derrière e siècle ces règles
qui donnent est applicable pour
s'assurer de du côté référence
commission européenne notre position de
ce sénateur c'est que la taxe n'est pas
affectée donc si jamais la taxe sur les
opérateurs
après les deux mois qui sont donnés un
gouvernement pour s'expliquer devaient
être annulés et je crois que le ministre
a évoqué hier à cannes très précisément
ça ne remet pas en cause les les budgets
de france télévisions la taxe n'a pas
affecté
donc c'est un problème pour les finances
publiques éventuellement mais ce n'est
pas et ça le ministre admire plaisir
c'est pas un problème de budget de
france télévisions concernant la
suppression de la publicité dans le
cadre du contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens cinq ans moi ma position à ce
jour est de dire que si nous négocions
un contrat d'objectifs et de moyens avec
des ambitions très clair en termes
d'objectifs qui correspondrait à ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur le rôle de
france télévisions sur le rôle des
chaînes etc
nous mettrons nous mettrions des moyens
en face et ses moyens après pourrait
nous arriver d'une façon ou d'une autre
dans la position où je suis actuellement
ma question de fond est est gelée moyens
nécessaires pendant les cinq ans et
l'état peut-il s'engager sur ces moyens
nécessaires à l'état de nous dire enfin
y avoue parlement de nous dit
si ses moyens c'est de la pub ou si
c'est dû finances publiques
mais cet engagement
pardon je vous renvoie la balle mais cet
engagement sur les moyens est pour moi
essentiel dans le cas de la négociation
d'un contrat sur deux n'a pas de contrat
alors si vous anticipez qui a des
difficultés des finances publiques
durant plus que deux ans aussi mais je
m'en remets à votre sagesse et votre et
votre capacité à ercis je prêche dernier
point nos deux otages en afghanistan
d'abord c'est assez c'est une question
qui secoue l'entreprise profondément
parce que il ya des réseaux de
solidarité mais aussi un rapport au
métier
vous imaginez tout cela au point où nous
en sommes
le sénateur au point où nous en sommes
des négociations congelés site tous les
jours ou qu on les cite pas ça change
pas grand chose sur les négociations en
cours et le fait de les citer c'est un
moment donné dans la dans la gradation
le fait de dire ben voilà il ya une
mobilisation de l'entreprise et une
prise à témoin d'aidé de nos concitoyens
moi je suis très frappé et je le dis là
des élus de la manière dont les
municipalités se sont dans toute la
france se mobilise et vous avez dans
beaucoup de mairies des affiches enfin
il ya quelque chose qui se passe voilà
vous savez dans cette négociation qui
est vraiment remarquablement menée par
les services de l'état ont su je suis ça
et il ya une vraie prise en compte
à un moment donné de cette question de
la mobilisation c'est peut-être
davantage pour soutenir les familles et
pour leur envoyer un signal parce que ce
que nous disent d'anciens otages
florence aubenas a encore témoigné
l'autre jour c'est que de cette
mobilisation elle entendait des échos
parce que vous avez un geôlier qui vous
fait entendre radio france
internationale parce que ces voix là
mais mais on est aussi très très clair
c'est pas parce qu'on se mobilise qu on
le libèrera plus vite ou plus lentement
derrière malheureusement monsieur le
président je crois que nous pouvons que
vous redire la totale solidarité de nos
commission et du parlement sur le
dernier point vous ne l'exprimé qui nous
que tous au combien vous remercier
d'être venu ici et présenter votre
action et votre engagement vous dire que
nous resterons évidemment tout à fait à
l écoute de ce que vous faites en
dialogue avec vous parce que nous
attachons à plus grande importance ce
que l'audiovisuel public et les moyens
de son action et puisse continuer à
répondre à l'attenté des français voilà
pourquoi nous nous posons beaucoup de
questions mais où
c'est bien la preuve de l'intérêt que
nous vous portons notre rôle n'est pas
simplement de contribuer à la
désignation des responsables de lever le
public mais aussi et surtout de suivre
leurs actions et de soutenir leurs
actions
merci beaucoup pour votre écoute merci
beaucoup
que l'on nous dise est financé à 100 %
n'est déjà plus suffisante et avec la
réforme actuelle dès l'année prochaine
il manquera 25 milliards vous l'aurez
compris votre projet de loi est injuste
socialement et inefficace économiquement
c'est pourquoi nous proposons un autre
chemin et je demande aux membres de la
majorité qui trop souvent nous disent ne
pas avoir de propositions de bien
vouloir les écouter contrairement à
l'idée que vous avez tenté un effet sans
succès d'installer dans les têtes
nous ne sommes pas dans le refus de la
réforme nous ne sommes pas dans leskiw
tout comme nos collègues à l'assemblée
nationale nous ne nous nous ne nous
arrêtons pas au milieu du chemin
nous ne nous contentons pas de dénoncer
votre pratique de la réforme ni de
contester le projet que vous nous
présenter car personne ne peut nier la
nécessité d'une réforme mais une réforme
qui apporterait des solutions et les
avancées véritable oui nous portons un
autre projet nous portons une réforme
globale
là où vous bornez à faire des mesures
démographiques l'unique axe de votre
projet de loi elle est indissociable de
cette réforme d'une autre politique de
l'emploi de l'emploi des jeunes et des
seniors en particulier notre projet
alternatif de réforme des retraites à
l'efficacité pour objectif est la
justice pour nous seule la justice c'est
d'abord de garantir de niveau de vie des
retraités aujourd'hui dégradé par votre
faute puisque les réformes balladur et
fillon ont conduits jusqu'à 20 % de
diminution des retraites
c'est une perte sèche monsieur le
rapporteur de pouvoir d'achat
la justice se soit ensuite des efforts
partagés alors qu'aujourd'hui 90% des
efforts sont demandés aux seuls salariés
c'est pour cela que nous proposons de
nouvelles ressources
nous proposons de mettre les revenus du
capital à contribution cela signifie
augmentation des prélèvements sociaux
sur les bonus et sur les stock options
conformément d'ailleurs
aux propositions de la cour des comptes
et application de la csg sur les revenus
du capital actuellement exonérés si
notre projet était adopté les
contribution des revenus du capital
s'élèverait à 10 9 milliards dès 2010 et
à 25 milliards en 2025 contre 2
milliards seulement dans votre projet et
nous acceptons une augmentation modérée
des cotisations patronales et salariales
de 0,1 point par an au cours des dix
années à venir
la justice aussi c'est de prendre en
compte la pénibilité et d'en tirer des
conséquences concrètes en matière
d'ouverture des droits à pension
nous devons acte est un principe simple
tout période de travail pénibles que ce
soit de travail de nuit
que ce soit du travail à la chaîne que
ce soit du port de charges lourdes doit
ouvrir droit à une majoration des
annuités et permettre de partir plus tôt
à la retraite
car oui oui ceux qui souffrent plus
doivent voir leurs souffrances reconnue
et récompensée au moment où ils quittent
la vie active
l'efficacité c'est de faire une réforme
durable
alors que votre projet n'apporte aucune
solution pérenne
pas même à moyen terme pour ceux là
n'auront pas contrairement à vous une
déviance coupable à l'égard du fonds de
réserve pour les retraites créé comme un
facteur de sécurité et de stabilité par
lionel jospin
depuis 2002 vous n'avez plus alimentée
et vous l'avez même parfois ponctionnés
vous avez ainsi vous avez ainsi
transformer le fonds de réserve pour les
retraites à un fonds de retraite sans
réserve
nous proposons nous proposons au
contraire de l'alimenter de manière
régulière par la création d'une surtaxe
par la création d'une surtaxe de 15% de
l'impôt sur les sociétés acquitté par
les banques qui une fois n'est pas
coutume peuvent fournir leur
contribution à l'effort nation
nous proposons enfin des points d'étape
réguliers tous les cinq ans avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
institut de clause de rendez-vous
globale sur le système des retraites
en 2025 c'est ainsi que nous
parviendrons à inscrire les choses dans
le long terme et à procéder à une
réforme durable des retraites
l'efficacité d'efficacité c'est aussi
être pragmatique en cohérence avec la
société et les modes de vie
d'aujourd'hui ainsi comment pouvez-vous
sérieusement imposé aux seniors de
travailler plus longtemps alors que la
france est la lanterne rouge de l'europe
pour le taux d'emploi des 55-64 ans quel
est le sens quelle est la faisabilité de
vos propositions dans un tel contexte
pour notre part nous proposons nous
proposons d'aller largement au delà de
votre réforme purement comptable en
prenant le problème de l'emploi des
seniors à bras le corps
nous voulons un vrai accompagnement des
salariés
nous voulons favoriser la formation des
seniors et nous pensons qu'il faut
revoir les méthodes de travail dans les
entreprises
en généralisant le tutorat et les
binômes en aménageant les conditions de
travail des plus de 55 ans pourquoi
enfin ne pas mettre en place un
mécanisme de bonus malus
par exemple la modulation de 1 point de
cotisation patronale en fonction de la
part des seniors parmi les salariés
faute d'appréhender l'emploi des seniors
dans sa globalité et dans sa complexité
votre projet de loi passe totalement à
côté de l'enjeu majeur du monde du
travail d'aujourd'hui car vous ne
réussirez jamais la quadrature du cercle
forcer des gens à travailler plus
longtemps alors qu'au delà d'un certain
âge aujourd'hui il devient souvent
presque impossible de trouver un emploi
au final ce que nous proposons c'est
d'aller vers la retraite choisie
ce n'est pas une formule magique ce
n'est pas raser gratis
c'est au contraire une vraie réforme de
société qui permettra d'aller vers un
système de retraite à la fois
universelle et personnalisée c'est la
seule manière de s'adapter horrible de
travail et de vie d'aujourd'hui c'est la
seule manière de tenir compte des
parcours et des perspectives de chacun
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
depuis des mois on veut nous présenter
les mesures contenues dans ce projet de
loi comme inéluctable depuis des mois on
fait appel à de fausses évidences sur
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
sans jamais tenir compte des différences
d'espérance de vie
selon les métiers depuis des mois on des
peines autres pays comme un village
gaulois qui résistera obstinément
changement en oubliant au passage que
chez nos voisins espagnols ou allemands
on s'est d'abord donner le temps de la
discussion le temps de la négociation
est le temps de la mise en oeuvre
on peut partir chez eux à la retraite au
terme de 35 ans de cotisation sans être
lourdement pénalisés pourtant en matière
de retraite
pas plus qu'ailleurs il n'ya de fatalité
une vraie réforme des retraites est
possible elle est finançable
elle est même souhaitable dès lors
qu'elle s'inscrit dans une approche
globale de notre économie et de notre
société
chers collègues il ne s'agit en aucun
cas au travers de cette motion
référendaire de se défausser de notre
responsabilité de parlementaires qui
doivent se saisir de toutes les grandes
réformes nécessaires notre pays
il ne s'agit pas de se substituer non
plus à l'expression nécessaire de la
démocratie sociale il ne s'agit pas de
proposer des référendums qui porterait
sur tous les sujets mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation la
situation d'une parole présidentielle
solennellement affirmé puis
véritablement trahi
et ce et ceux ci on est sur une réforme
considérée au plus haut sommet de l'état
quand même eu la réforme majeure du
quinquennat
oui il faut que nicolas sarkozy décide
enfin de tout remettre à plat et
reprennent les choses à l'endroit
plutôt qu'un débat sur l'identité
nationale de ceux qui ne serait-il pas
plus utile ne serait-il pas temps
d'engager un débat national sur ce point
précis de savoir si le président peut
faire l'exact contraire de ce qu'il
avait proposé aux français
l'ouverture l'ouverture des droits à la
retraite dès l'âge de 60 ans
c'est à lui qu'il appartient de décider
de la forme que ce débat pourrait
prendre
c'est à lui de consulter les français
c'est dans cet esprit madame la
présidente
au nom du groupe socialiste j'ai
l'honneur de demander et du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen parti de
gauche j'ai l'honneur de demander à
notre assemblée d'adopter la motion
référendaire que nous avons déposée
faute de débat et d'écouté nous
utilisons cet ultime recours et nous
lançons un appel solennel et grave à
tous les républicains qui n'acceptent
pas le caractère injuste et inique de ce
projet de loi
un appel à de nombreux collègues surtout
les rangs de cette assemblée qui au fond
d'eux mêmes n'accepte pas le caractère
profondément choquant du texte qui nous
est proposé oui je lance un appel à
toutes celles et ceux qui croient comme
nous que la république française on
était le même que lorsqu'elle est
démocratique et sociale ne votez pas
cette réforme injuste
oui
mes chers collègues
mes chers collègues avant de donner la
parole à monsieur dominique leclerc j'ai
le plaisir de saluer la présence dans
notre tribune d'honneur de monsieur al
maya bully sénateur de la république
islamique d'afghanistan qui effectue
toute cette semaine une visite de
travail auprès de notre assemblée en
compagnie de deux fonctionnaires du
sénat afghan
qu'il me soit permis de rappeler que
c'est grâce au soutien des
administrateurs de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat français qu'ont pu être
formé sous l'égide du programme des
nations unies pour le développement au
cours de l'été 2005
les 100 premiers fonctionnaires des deux
assemblées composant le parlement afghan
depuis cette date c'est plus d'une
cinquantaine de parlementaires et de
fonctionnaires de ces assemblées qui
n'auront pu être informés ou formés
grâce à la coopération de notre sénat à
paris ou à kaboul en regard de la
présence militaire française en
afghanistan il importe de rappeler cette
coopération pacifique au service de la
démocratie
je souhaite en notre nom à tous la
bienvenue à notre collègue zalmaï
rabouli auquel je souhaite un séjour
fructueux et agréable dans notre pays
allez
la parole est à monsieur dominique
leclerc rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales
oui
madame la présidente de monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues hier une
motion référendaire signé par les
membres donc des groupes socialistes et
communistes a été déposé en séance par
leur président
cette motion met en oeuvre et ce pour la
première fois dans notre commission la
nouvelle procédure qui a été adoptée à
l'article 46 de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 article oui
qui a réformé donc l'article 11 de la
constitution en permettant d'organiser
un référendum d'initiative parlementaire
bénéficiant d'un soutien populaire sur
la forme tout d'abord je vous indique
que malheureusement la loi organique
nécessaire à la mise en oeuvre de cette
nouvelle procédure de référendum n'est
toujours pas adopté ni même encore
déposé à l'état de projet
s'il vous plaît la logique la logique
devrait donc conduire la commission à
émettre un avis défavorable à cette
motion
ceci étant ceci étant je ne voudrais pas
donner l'impression de me réfugier
derrière cet argument technique facile
et je suis d'accord avec les signataires
pour dire que la question des retraites
est en ce moment très légitimement au
coeur des préoccupations de tous nos
concitoyens pour autant pour autant si
je reprends brièvement les quatre
arguments développés par les auteurs de
la motion
je ne puis les considérer comme
convaincant le premier argument oppose
au président de la république le fait
que la réforme a été engagée sans mandat
du peuple
or or outre que la constitution déclare
que tout mandat impératif est nul c'est
l'inaction du gouvernement qui pourrait
juger gravement fautive face à la
situation dégradée des comptes sociaux
le deuxième le deuxième affirme vote
deuxième argument
écoutez vous affirmez l'absence de
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux est aussi le manque de respect
du parlement corps ministre et le débat
à l'assemblée nationale
je ne puis suivent sur l'un ou l'autre
de ces deux terrains la concertation et
ça a été rappelé hier suppose que les
deux parties aient bien s'y montre
consentants et d'autre part l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le texte ce texte
dans les rets troisième argument ce
troisième prétend que la pénibilité de
certains métiers n'est pas prise en
compte
me paraît il faut encore le répéter un
peu caricatural
si j'en juge si j'en juge par le temps
que nous avons passé sur cette question
en commission
vous savez bien que la france sera le
premier pays à reconnaître
officiellement la pénibilité
enfin enfin enfin s'il vous plaît le
quatrième le quatrième et dernier
argument qui soutient que des projets
alternatifs sont concevables des projets
alternatifs sont concevables vous le
savez très bien il me convient
parfaitement
je plein moi même et depuis longtemps
pour confrères réfléchissent à
l'opportunité d'une réforme systémique
chers collègues vous l'avez bien compris
donc je vous propose deux devait de
donner un avis défavorable à cette
motion
merci
la parole est un monsieur eric woerth
ministre du travail de la solidarité et
de la fonction publique et ses ministres
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les les sénateurs
voulaient vous oui ou non sauvegarder
notre système de retraite
merci merci merci merci ça me touche ça
me touche au coeur c'est la seule
question qui vaille
et c'est la seule question qui mérite
d'être posée aux français et 7 et à
cette question évidemment la réponse est
oui
les partenaires sociaux les partenaires
sociaux les partis politiques que j'ai
consultés chacun de nous en est enfin
d'accord nous voulons une réforme du
système de retraite par répartition
nous voulons sauvegarder notre système
par répartition alors il est certain que
réformer nos retraites cela demande à
tous les français de faire un effort est
demandé à chacun de faire des efforts
cela n'est jamais populaire cela demande
du courage monsieur le président du
groupe socialiste dans ce monde de plus
en plus difficile d'ailleurs gouverner
demande du courage nous ne manquons pas
nous n'en manquons pas et avec le
président de la république notre
majorité
une nouvelle fois en témoigne comme elle
a su en témoigner en 1993 en 2003 et en
2007 2008 sur les retraites
la proposition que fait aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste c'est une façon
d'éviter le débat sur le fond sur le
sujet de la réforme des retraites
comme vous n'êtes pas à l'aise sur le
fond comme vous n'avez pas de projet
vous vous interrogez sur la forme ce
n'est pas autre chose
et d'ailleurs ce que vous avez dit ce
que vous avez dit aux rapporteurs
monsieur leclerc sur la procédure de
référendum
encore aurait il fallu que vous vous
sentiez la réforme constitutionnelle
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
ça n'a pas été le cas alors demandé que
s'applique une procédure contenu dans
une réforme dont vous n'avez pas voulu
c'est un peu la même logique que celle
que vous déployez sur la réforme des
retraites
aujourd'hui alors que l'assemblée
nationale a voté cette réforme
après de longs débats jour et nuit alors
que le débat parlementaire se poursuit
au sénat devant votre haute assemblée
alors que le débat parlementaire se
poursuit comme il est normal dans une
démocratie et comme la nôtre vous nous
dites que la représentation nationale
n'est pas qualifié pour débattre des
retraites et vous brandissez le
référendum
moi je pense que la représentation
nationale et le sénat sont qualifiés
pour discuter des retraites puis-je
également vous demander monsieur le
président du groupe socialiste de
respecter le règlement de l'assemblée
nationale dont vous avez fait des
commentaires qui ne me semble pas
opportun
alors si l'on suit votre logique il
faudrait faire un référendum à chaque
fois que l'on fait une réforme des
retraites
pourtant vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas
fait de référendum pour revenir sur la
réforme des retraites de 1993 quand vous
étiez aux responsabilités alors que vous
avez demandé sans arrêt de supprimer
cette réforme
vous prétendez avoir fait une réforme
des retraites quand vous avez créé le
fonds de réserve des retraites
mais vous n'avez pas fait de référendum
à ce moment là ce n'était d'ailleurs
probablement pas une réforme c'est la
seule le
ce que je trouve à cela entre nous
d'ailleurs monsieur le président vous
avez parlé du fonds de réserve des
retraites
sitôt l'avoir créé madame aubry l'a
immédiatement ponctionner pour financer
les 35 heures la première à avoir
fonctionné
le fonds de réserve des retraites pour
alimenter le forex de l'époque c'est
madame au bruit alors vous nous
reprochez aujourd'hui d'utiliser le
fonds de réserve des retraites pour
financer les retraites
madame aubry a utilisé le jeune fonds de
réserve des retraites pour financer les
35 heures cherchez l'erreur cherchez
l'erreur sur les retraites il s'agit
d'avancer des propositions
il s'agit de répondre à l'urgence de
déficit de nos régimes de retraites en
rétablissant leur équilibre
il s'agit de construire des solutions
dans la durée pour les générations qui
viennent et pour que ces générations
puissent à leur tour bénéficier de notre
système par répartition qui est un
système solidaire c'est pour cela que
nous avons ce temps de débat article par
article amendement par amendement nous y
prendrons le temps qu'il faut sur tous
les sujets clés d'une réforme des
retraites l'âge bien sûr débat important
parce que c'est le socle d'un système
par répartition mais aussi la santé au
travail la pénibilité les carrières
longues les inégalités retraite entre
les hommes et les femmes
les différences entre le secteur privé
et le secteur public
les travailleurs handicapés les seniors
il y à de multiples questions qui se
posent et à ces questions le
gouvernement répond mais ces questions
sont des questions de débats que nous
aurons ici je les imagine en profondeur
alors si vous posez par référendum
la question qu'on sent diriez vous à
payer plus d'impôts et de cotisations
pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite qu'on sentiriez-vous à payer
plus de 40 milliards d'euros d'impôts et
de taxes supplémentaires comme le
propose le parti socialiste
véritable bombardement fiscale qui rit
nu est à la fois notre compétitivité
pénaliserait l'emploi et diminuerait le
pouvoir d'achat des français
la réponse elle est toute trouvée c'est
pas la peine de faire un référendum ce
sera non les français ne voudront pas de
votre proposition de réforme des
retraites ou encore si vous posez la
question autrement puisque madame aubry
appelle à une baisse des retraites
accepteriez-vous de baisser votre
pension de 10 % pour financer les
retraites
la réponse elle serait évidemment non
parce que si on ne touche pas à l'âge de
la retraite alors pour rétablir
l'équilibré il faut baisser les pensions
et il faut les baissiers
aujourd'hui de 10 % et en 2025 de 15%
c'est ça la réalité évidemment personne
ne le chouette et surtout pas le
gouvernement ni la majorité alors votre
référendum il ne servirait à rien il ne
résoudrait rien il ne permettrait
d'avancer sur rien surtout ne rien
décider
voilà votre ligne de conduite on le voit
sur un sujet aussi vaste que les
retraites
le choix du référendum est une impasse
nous devons écouter les français
mais nous devons aussi savoir prendre
nos responsabilités
les français n'attendent pas qu'on soit
dans l'inaction les français même si
c'est difficile même si c'est difficile
attendre qu répondre à leurs
préoccupations
ils attendent de nous que nous
garantissions nos régimes de retraite
par répartition et nous le faisons
ils attendent de nous que nous prenions
en compte la situation de ceux qui ont
des carrières pénibles et nous le
faisons
il attend de nous que nous prenions en
compte la situation de ceux qui ont eu
des carrières longues et nous le faisons
ils attendent de nous que nous agissions
sur les vraies causes des écarts de
pension entre les hommes et les femmes
nous le faisons et le débat au sénat ce
sera sans doute l'occasion d'enrichir
notre texte encore et toujours sur ce
sujet et ils attendent d'eux
où les français que nous prenions en
compte la situation des retraités les
plus modestes nous l'avons fait et nous
continuons de le faire notamment
concernant les agriculteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
le gouvernement n'est pas dans
l'incantation
l'idéologie le gouvernement est dans la
responsabilité et dans la réalité vous
prétendez monsieur le président que nous
n'avons pas de mandat pour agir que le
président de la république n'aurait pas
de mandat pour agir en matière de
retraite c'est probablement le fait que
vous n'ayez jamais agi sur ce sujet là
qui vous donne cette expérience mais je
voudrais juste vérifier que vous étiez
bien au courant d'un scoop
savez vous qu'il ya eu une crise
économique
savez vous qu'il y a eu la crise
économique la plus importante que le
monde est eu à affronter et cela a
changé la donne pour longtemps en
matière de retraites il faut juste que
vous ayez bien cela présent à l'esprit
et nous vous le rappellerons et nous
vous le rappelons notamment lorsque nous
parlerons des mesures de financement
nous aurions pu ne rien faire comme vous
le souhaitez nous aurions pu ne rien
changer
attendre que les déficits de retraite se
creuse jour après jour
mais la première qualité la première
qualité d'un homme d'état c'est
s'adapter et c'est le cas du président
de la république française c'est de
s'adapter et ce n'est pas d'oublier la
réalité le mandat nous ont donné les
français quand ils ont élu le président
de la république ce n'est pas le faire
choix de l'immobilisme c'est de faire le
choix de l'action et de la
responsabilité
alors ce n'est pas alors ce n'est pas
parce que le parti socialiste a un
problème avec les retraites qu'il faut
refuser de répondre aux vrais problèmes
des français celui du financement de
notre système de retraite
avec ce projet de loi nous y répondons
et prenons devant les français nos
responsabilités
la parole est à monsieur jacky le menn
pour le groupe socialiste
on se bouge pas
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues une réforme des retraites ne
peut se faire sans l'accord très large
de nos concitoyens c'est loin d'être le
cas
le gouvernement reste sourd à leurs voix
dont l'écho lui parvient pas par les
manifestations monstres des 7 et 23
septembre et du 2 octobre dernier que
par les sondages successifs
initié par les médias et aussi par
l'interpellation de son opposition
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
et ici même au sénat en commission des
affaires sociales est depuis hier dans
l'hémicycle
enfin ce n'est pas le moindre des
paradoxes
qu'en pense le rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales je vous
rappelle que le président de la
république lui même a déclaré dans un
passé pas si lointain 2007 qu'il n'avait
pas été mandatée donc élu pour modifier
l'âge légal d'ouverture des droits à la
retraite des français le président notre
route sans peyrebelle la forte à propos
rappelé voici quelques instants dans ces
conditions il apparaît indispensable de
prendre la voie référendaire pour faire
trancher par les français qui sont les
premiers concernés les points clés dont
dispose le projet de loi du gouvernement
avec en premier lieu le recul de l'âge
légal du départ en retraite de 60 à 62
ans comme celui du depor de 65 à 67 ans
de l'âge d'obtention d'un taux plein
monsieur le ministre si une réforme des
retraites est effectivement nécessaire
notamment pour des raisons de
financement que personne ne réfute
nous ne cessons de le déclarer et il
faut beaucoup de surdité sélective ou de
mauvaise foi pour ne pas l'entendre
par contre celles que vous nous
soumettez est à la fois injuste brutale
et inefficace et inéquitable
comme le souligne à juste titre toutes
les grandes confédérations syndicales de
notre pays et comme l'a rappelé hier le
colloque notre collègue christiane
demontès au cours du débat général sur
ce projet et à l'instar notre collègue
jean pierre bel
les confédérations syndicales dénoncent
par ailleurs une concertation en trompe
l'oeil qui en fait n'a trompé personne
nos concitoyens n'étant pas des naïfs
tous ont bien compris que seul le medef
était écoutée au plus haut sommet de
l'état sur ce dossier des retraites
comme sur bien d'autres
tout d'abord rappelons qu'à la question
des retraites ne peut pas se limiter à
ces dimensions comptable elle est par
essence sociétale elle nécessite de plus
une véritable négociation avec les
représentants du monde du travail
négociations qui malgré vos dénégations
monsieur lemay drizzt n'a pas eu lieu
elle requiert enfin un débat de fond où
les thèmes de l'emploi et du travail
devait très devraient être abordés afin
que la retraite par répartition retrouve
la confiance de toutes les générations
que proposez-vous en réponse à cet enjeu
majeur pour nos concitoyens
premièrement un projet de loi qui est
injuste et salariés qui ont commencé à
travailler jeunes devront cotiser plus
longtemps que les autres
sans amélioration de leur pension or 50
% des nouveaux recrutés la caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse ont
d'ores et déjà cotisé à 60 ans au moins
un trimestre au delà d'une carrière
complète sans acquérir de droits
nouveaux
si le dispositif de départs anticipés
pour carrière longue et maintenu c'est
en laissant de côté toutes celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler à 18
ans et qui devront cotiser 44 ans les
salariés qui sont hors de l'emploi au
moment où ils partent à la retraite soit
près de six français sur dix seront
amenés à rester au chômage en maladie ou
d'invalidité plus longtemps avec des
allocations bien souvent plus faibles
que leurs droits à la retraite
les situations de travail pénibles ne
sont pas reconnus par le projet de loi
qui s'adresse uniquement aux salariés
ayant déjà des atteintes à la santé à
l'âge de 60 ans
la réforme est injuste pour les salariés
exposés à la pénibilité qui ont une
espérance de vie réduite en moyenne de 3
à 4 heures par rapport à l'ensemble des
salariés
enfin l'état actuel des propositions du
gouvernement
la traçabilité de la pénibilité ne
s'appuie pas sur les caisses de retraite
et ne permet aucune
actions de prévention neil compensation
les fonctionnaires subissent une
réduction de leur pouvoir d'achat à
travers un rattrapage de toutes
cotisations salariales de 7 85% à 10 55%
sans compensation et en période de gel
des salaires en nous savons ce que la
valeur du point est gelée pour trois ans
les conditions d'accès au minimum
garantis seront plus restrictive ce qui
ampute aura les droits des
fonctionnaires les plus modestes
notamment les femmes les salariés aux
carrières incomplètes
voilà le départ sans pénalité les
fameuses décote reculé de 65 à 67 ans
entre 2016 et 2021
les femmes seront particulièrement
concernées est dramatique et
dramatiquement pénalisés ce qui est
inadmissible
près de 30% d'entre elles partent
actuellement en retraite à 65 ans les
bas salaires seront défavorisées dans le
public comme dans le privé
un complément de pension au titre du
million de contributif et vers 6 à 42 %
des nouveaux retraités du privé et à 75%
de ceux qui partent en retraite à 65 ans
avec cette réforme les bas salaires ont
donc plus de difficultés à accéder aux
mesures qui compense partiellement la
faiblesse de leurs droits à la retraite
le projet de loi prévoit la prise en
compte des indemnités journalières
maternité dans le calcul des pensions
des mères de famille outre le fait que
ces périodes ne sont pas considérés
comme cotisé ce qui a une incidence sur
les départs anticipés pour carrière
longue
cette mesure est très insuffisante au
regard des écarts de pension entre les
femmes et hommes ceux qui ont cotisé à
plusieurs régimes de retraite sont
toujours aussi pénalisé le projet de loi
évoque à peine évoque à peine la
situation des polypensionnés
alors qu'ils représentent jugez du peu
près de 40% des nouveaux retraités
deuxièmement un projet de loi qui est
brutale le nombre d'intervenants dans le
débat général dès hier et cette nuit
nous l'ont à de multiples reprises
répété il combine deux paramètres dans
des délais très brefs
un recul des bornes d'âge de quatre mois
par année civile entre 2011 et 2016 est
une arme une augmentation d'un trimestre
dès 2013 de la durée de cotisation pour
une retraite à taux plein porté à 41 25
années dans les fonctions publiques une
révision à la baisse du montant des
pensions affectera tous les départs
anticipés des parents de trois enfants
qui déposeront leurs dossiers à compter
du présent 1er janvier 2011 alors même
que l'emploi des seniors est une
priorité
cette décision incitera les femmes
fonctionnaires concernés à partir en
retraite le plus rapidement possible
troisièmement un projet de loi qui est
inefficace
le projet ne vise que le court terme
j'ai déjà eu hélas l'occasion de le
déplorer à cette tribune il y a quelques
semaines lorsque nous avons examiné le
projet de loi organique sur la dette
sociale
l'équilibré financier à l'horizon 2008
18 n'est assuré qu'en transférant des
charges vers l'assurance chômage et
l'assurance maladie qui ne sont pas
comptabilisés votre réforme des
retraites aura ainsi un impact net sur
l'étang de l'assurance chômage à partir
de 2015 qui culminera entre 440 et 530
millions d'euros en 2018 selon les
estimations de l'unedic
rien n'est prévu pour équilibrer le
système de retraite au delà de 2018
bien que vous en défendiez par des
assertions nullement convaincante et les
déficits continueront à se creuser alors
même que le recul des bornes d'âge aura
produit tout son effet est que le fonds
de réserve des retraites aura été
liquidée enfin le texte ne répond pas à
la situation de l'emploi qui conditionne
en grande partie l'avenir des retraites
la création d'une aide à l'embauché des
seniors ignore les questions
fondamentales des conditions de travail
et des aménagements de fin de carrière
quatrièmement un projet de loi qui est
inéquitable
ce saut et on l'a déjà dit
essentiellement les travailleurs
salariés qui devront prendre en charge
les conséquences de la crise
ils fournissent 85% de l'effort
financier principalement à travers le
recul de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 60 à 62 ans d'ici 2016
le recours à la fiscalité notamment sur
les contribuables les plus fortunés et
la taxation des revenus des capitaux
restent symboliques et concours
seulement à 15 % des financements
le projet est également inéquitable pour
les plus jeunes générations car ils
dilapident et c'est déplorable des
ressources du fonds de réserve des
retraites pour éponger
partie des déficits dus à la crise alors
que ce fonds est destiné à faire face
dès 2020 à l'arrivée à la retraite des
générations nombreuses du papy boom
il crée ainsi les conditions d'une
augmentation des déficits futurs qui
reposeront alors sur les seules épaules
des plus jeunes générations
d'autres solutions pour résorber un
déficit dû à la crise était possible les
orateurs de mon groupe et moi même en
ont évoqué certaines lors du récent
débat sur la dette sociale
nous y reviendrons dans la suite du
présent débat votre choix de siphonner
sans délai le fonds de réserve des
retraites étant dit il dit quoi que vous
en disiez monsieur le ministre un
mauvais coup porté aux générations
futures
celle de nos enfants c'est que ceux qui
plus qu'une erreur et une faute dans
vous aurez ainsi que monsieur le
président de la république à rendre
compte devant nos concitoyens de voir
les générations futures et devant
l'histoire triste projet en vérité
monsieur le ministre
éloigné de toute perspective de réformes
j'ai fumé madame la présidente est
solidaire car où serait le progrès si la
sauvegarde de notre système de retraites
devait se traduire par des inégalités
croissantes plus d'individualisme
davantage d'insécurité de précarité pour
les uns et toujours plus de privilèges
pour les autres dans ces conditions
monsieur le ministre la consultation de
notre peuple par voie référendaire sa
cause
mes chers collègues avant de donner la
parole aux prochains orateurs je précise
que les temps de paroles doivent être
respectées ne comptez pas ne comptez pas
sur mon indulgence
quel que soit ce premier mauvais exemple
je donne la parole à monsieur jean louis
masson non inscrit de faire attention
quand même
oui mais
madame le président monsieur many chers
collègues tous les pays européens de
membres de l'union européenne ont été
obligés de prendre des mesures sérieuses
pour tenir compte de la nécessité
d'équilibrer les retraites
moi je pense à titre personnel que si la
france avait une recette miracle pour
maintenir la retraite à 60 ans ça se
saurait et que nos voisins allemands nos
voisins luxembourgeois nos voisins
hollandais les suédois les autres qui ne
sont pas plus bêtes que nous aurait
certainement découvert la martingale en
même temps que nous elle aurait utilisé
alors très honnêtement très honnêtement
je veux redire à à certains de nos
collègues que manifestement si on veut
assurer l'avenir des retraites
il est évident qu'il faut prendre un
certain nombre de mesures est à
l'évidence le relèvement de l'âge de la
retraite et fait partie de ces mesures
donc à titre personnel à titre personnel
je suis tout à fait favorable au
relèvement de l'âge de la retraite de 60
à 62 ans et je pense même je pense même
que dans dix ans dans 15 ans ceux qui
nous succéderont seront peut-être amenés
compte tenu de la poursuite de
l'allongement des durées ji de
réexaminer de réexaminer même ce seuil
de 62 ans
ceci étant il y a j'ai pour ma part il
ya deux points moi qui me font qui me
pose problème dans cette réforme
c'est tout d'abord le passage de 65 à 67
ans de l'âge pour
le bénéfice de la retraite dit complète
alors je crois quelqu'un quelqu'un qui a
cotisé pendant 20 ans quand on lui donne
sa retraite soit disant complète on lui
donne au prorata des vingt ans donc si
cette personne n'arrive à 60 ou 62 ans
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on la taxe une
deuxième fois en lui en exigeant d'elle
que par rapport à d'autres
et bien cette personne soient obligés de
cotiser plus longtemps et donc je pense
que mathématiquement statistiquement il
est tout à fait anormal de demander à
quelqu'un synapp ci n'a que 20 ans de
cotisations aujourd'hui demander
aujourd'hui travailler je 65 ans c'est
déjà une injustice actuelle et il est
tout aussi anormal de demander à une
personne quand on aura passé à 32 ans
lui dire ben vous trahit que 67 ans mais
de toute manière quand vous aurez trajet
67 ans vous aurez que votre retraite
proportionnelle comme tous les autres
dont vous avez au prorata de 20 ans les
auditions prorata de 2 40 annuités et
cetera donc là il y à une injustice mais
mathématiques au niveau profond dans ce
système et c'est du point de vue social
c'est d'autant plus injuste monsieur
ministre et vous le savez et moi je les
dis récemment aux rapporteurs de 2 sera
de ce rapport qui est de l'assemblée
nationale qui est par ailleurs un
parlementaire de la moselle je lui ai
dit que je ne comprenais pas son
acharnement sur ce relèvement de 65 à 67
ans de l'âge de la retraite
et c'est d'autant plus inadmissible que
finalement et vous le savez monsieur le
ministre ce sont ceux qui vont trinquer
se vont être ça va être les gens les
plus modestes
les gens qui ont des caissières qui ont
eu des caissières l'hypermarché qui au
travail et qui ont travaillé à mi-temps
sur pattes houleux qui ont déjà une
toute petite retraite et vous êtes en
train
monsieur le ministre de générer avec
cette ce relèvement du seuil à 67 ans
vous êtes en train de générer des
cohortes de gens qui n'auront pas leur
retraite mais qui seront tout simplement
à peine au minimum vieillesse est là sur
ce point
à autant je suis tout à fait d'accord de
remonter l'aja retraite à 62 ans
autant je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
de faire en sorte que seul le seuil pour
la retraite soit disant plein mais qui
n'est pas une retraite pleine
c'est une retraite proportionnelle sans
abattement donc c'est le terme de dire
la retraite pleine
c'est une hypocrisie du gouvernement
c'est pas l'attrait plein c'est la
retraite proportionnelle sans abattement
et moi j'estime qu'il est indécent il
est indécent de remonter ce seuil à 67
ans et puis il y a monsieur le ministre
je voudrais vous dire monsieur le
ministre qui lie à un deuxième point moi
qui me choque c'est que on est dans la
difficulté c'est le sénateur on est je
conclu madame la présidente
on est dans la difficulté et je voudrais
dire que quand on est dans les gîtes
dans la difficulté il est normal que
tout le monde fasse des efforts donc
j'estime qu'il est normal qu'on remonte
l'âge de la retraite mais il est
indécent que le président de la
république s'accroche à certaines
réformes tout à fait disproportionnée
tels que par exemple le bouclier fiscal
c'est indécent et moi je crois je crois
qu'un gouvernement responsable ne peut
pas demander aux salariés et aux peaux
de faire un effort si aux super riches
et on en connaît y aller on en a parlé
dans l'actualité récente
et bien si aussi père riche on ne
demande rien donc monsieur le ministre
donc monsieur le ministre et j'en ai
terminé madame la présidente je voudrais
dire que le fond de la réforme qui
consiste à passer à 62 ans
je suis d'accord mais tout le reste je
suis pas d'accord et la politique
actuelle du gouvernement qui continue
dit long à avoir une politique à deux
vitesses au profit des régions au profit
des gens sur le bouclier fiscal c'est
indécent et donc je m'abstiendrai sur ce
vote
merci la parole est un monsieur robert
tropéano pour le rdse
et
ça va
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
on sait aujourd'hui qu'une très grande
majorité de français n'approuvent pas ce
projet de réforme des retraites
non pas qu'il désapprouve l'idée même
d'une réforme mais parce qu'ils l'ont
bien compris et ce malgré une large
campagne de communication sur fonds
publics que cette réforme
votre réforme monsieur le ministre porte
atteinte aux fondements mêmes de notre
république et à certains de ses
principes les plus fondamentaux la
solidarité l'égalité la justice
l'effort et le mérite autant de valeurs
partagées par l'ensemble des membres du
groupe rdse
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
et c'est l'objet de la motion qui
viennent de nous être présentée par le
président bayle
le moment est venu pour vous et votre
majorité d'entendre les français oui de
les entendre et en fait de les
considérer le président du sénat n'at-il
pas déclaré récemment sur cette question
qu'on le veuille ou non il y a des
interrogations dans le pays
il faut y répondre voilà des propos
pleins de sagesse qu'il serait bon de
mettre en pratique
alors quelles questions mais quelle
réponse apporter adressé aux français
dans un premier temps les antennes et d
écouter cela devienne une nécessité car
toute réforme des retraites ça leur
approbation est vouée à l'échec
dans un second temps il nous faut bâtir
vous avec nous une autre réforme
recommencer à zéro et prendre tout le
temps nécessaire pour négocier
véritablement avec les partenaires
sociaux et des forces politiques
la réforme doit se construire
collectivement et chacune des
sensibilités politiques et syndicales de
ce pays doit pouvoir apporter sa pierre
à l'édifice
c'est de cette façon et uniquement est
ici que le consensus peut être trouver
ce consensus
indispensable à la réussite d'une telle
réforme
ce consensus qui fait cruellement défaut
aujourd'hui
car sur le plan de la méthode vous avez
si je puis dire fait le minimum syndical
juste le temps de recevoir les
partenaires sociaux de prendre la
température et de faire quelques photos
à juin 2010 deux mois seulement après la
fin de ce que vous avez envie de m'en
rappeler les négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux mais qui est l
avantage de simples consultations
deux mois après vous déposiez sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale un
projet de loi portant réforme des
retraites
deux mois c'est bien peu pour préparer
une réforme de cette ampleur
une réforme qui touche au patrimoine
promène de tous les français à savoir le
système des retraites par répartition un
système construit après guerre et qui
fait encore la fierté de notre modèle
social
d'autant que vous avez une fois de plus
engagé la procédure accélérée empêchant
ainsi au débat et la discussion
parlementaire de prendre tout le temps
nécessaire
pourquoi monsieur le ministre dont la
retraitée ce dossier en urgence et dans
la précipitation
comment s'étonner alors de son caractère
bâclé après les services publics
après la poste après les collectivités
territoriales vous attaquer au système
par répartition pour le démanteler et
nous substituer des modèles risquée et
inadaptée des modèles reposant sur un
système financier en crise vous croyez
moderniser quand vous êtes à rebours de
l'histoire à ne tenant pas compte des
leçons de la très grave crise financière
mondiale dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons alors monsieur le ministre
devant un tel enjeu et parce que la
retraite est un droit fondamental auquel
les français sont profondément attachés
pourquoi autant d'empressement
pourquoi priver les français donnent
droit d'expression sur un jeu de société
aussi importante
c'est l'objet de cette motion
référendaire que pour ma part je voterai
convaincu que l'ensemble des citoyennes
de notre pays doit pouvoir se prononcer
sur l'objet même du projet de loi et
dire si oui ou non il l'a prouvé
le doute a ni de leur bon sens ni de la
réponse négative
les français vous obligeront alors à
revoir la copie et à produire un nouveau
texte nécessairement plus juste plus
ambitieux et plus respectueux des
valeurs de notre république
mes chers collègues puisque l'article 11
de la constitution prévoit la
possibilité de soumettre à référendum
tout projet de loi portant sur des
réformes relatives à la politique
sociale de la nation ce qui est le cas
de ce texte
eh bien je crois qu'il ne faut pas s'en
priver parce que le président de la
république avait promis qu'il ne
toucherait pas à la retraite à 60 ans
cela a été rappelé par plusieurs
orateurs et notamment par jean pierre
bel tout à l'heure par conséquent faute
d'avoir reçu le mandat du peuple
français lors de son élection au
suffrage universel et parce que cette
réforme véritable enjeu majeur de
société aura des conséquences pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
pour toutes ces raisons c'est aux
français de se prononcer sur cette
réforme
ensuite il nous reviendra à nous
représentants du peuple de construire
notre projet de proposer une alternative
au delà des clivages politiques dans la
recherche sincère du consensus le plus
large possible
il est temps d'entrer dans une
démocratie sociale et politique apaisée
et responsable aujourd'hui 71 % des
français rejettent massivement la
réforme telle que vous l'envisagez près
de 3 millions de salariés ont manifesté
leur opposition en descendant dans la
rue à plusieurs reprises les français à
commencer par les classes moyennes et
par les plus modestes sont inquiets
quant à l'avenir de leur retraite leur
contestation est légitime car votre
projet de loi pose de nombreux problèmes
cela a été dit par de nombreux orateurs
hier et cette nuit et notamment par mes
collègues
rd ce jean pierre plancade ou encore
françoise laborde vous prétendez
rétablir l'équilibré financier de notre
régime de retraite
d'une part c'est faux le compte n'y est
pas mais d'autre part c'est au prix de
nouveaux sacrifices encore une fois pour
les plus modestes et pour les classes
moyennes
tout d'abord vous pénaliser les
personnes qui ont commencé à travailler
très tôt et qui devront cotiser plus
longtemps que les autres
pourtant ces personnes ne connaissent
souvent des conditions de travail très
pénible et ont une espérance de vie
inférieure à la moyenne
certes vous proposer un dispositif leur
permettant de partir un peu plus tôt
mais cela leur impose malgré tout une
durée de cotisation très importante
beaucoup trop importante cette question
soulève un autre problème celui de
l'emploi des seniors en france le taux
d'emploi de la trèche des 55 64 eur
n'atteint que 40% alors que l'union
européenne avait fixé un objectif de 50
% pour 2010 en repoussant l'âge de
départ en retraite
vous risquez d'augmenter chômage et
précarité et par conséquent de diminuer
le niveau des positions
en effet près de 70% des français qui
liquident leur retraite aujourd'hui sans
emploi vous pénaliser les femmes les
femmes que souvent des carrières
incomplètes
actuellement les retraites des femmes
sont inférieures de 38 % à celle des
hommes et plus de la moitié touche une
position inférieure à 900 euros
cela est inacceptable cette inégalité
reflète parfaitement les inégalités
professionnelles qui se cumulent tout au
long de la carrière entre les hommes et
les femmes inégalités de salaires
inégalités au niveau des responsabilités
précarité et temps partiel subi
certains vous proposer de prendre en
compte les indemnités journalières de
maternité dans le salaire annuel qui
sert de calcul du droit patio mais cette
mesure ne sera applicable qu'aux zones
habitées versées à compter du 1er
janvier 2012 par ailleurs je doute
qu'elle permette de caen
penser le retard en matière d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
en revanche il est à craindre qu'un
recul de l'âge légal de la retraite et
l'âge d'annulation de la décote vous
condamniez ces femmes à une plus grande
des précarités
elles sont actuellement plus nombreuses
à liquider leurs droits à la retraite à
65 ans faute de n'avoir pu rassembler le
nombre de trimestres nécessaires pour
toucher une retraite à taux plein mais
le taux d'emploi des femmes n'est plus
60 tonnes est très faible
elles sont donc nombreuses avant 65 ans
à connaître une situation de chômage ou
de précarité vous pénalisez également
une les salariés qui exercent ce métier
pénible et dont l'espérance de vie est
de facto réduite sur cette question je
ne peux que regretter que les
négociations sur la pénibilité n'est pas
avancé et les mesures de votre projet de
loi sont très nettement insuffisantes et
surtout injuste puisque vous confondez
pénalité pénibilité et incapacités le
président de la république au lendemain
de la manifestation du 7 septembre
dernier s'est dit attentive aux
préoccupations qui s'est exprimé cet
énième fed annonce n'a malheureusement
pas race rassurer les français sur
l'avenir de leur tête
car il ne règle en rien les problèmes de
fond de la réforme pour engager une
telle forme un grand débat de société
un grand débat public aurait été
nécessaire mais vous l'avez refusé le
recours au référendum demandé par la
présente motion est probablement
l'ultime possibilité pour permettre la
tenue de ce grand débat dans tout le
pays et entre tous les français pour les
associer pleinement à la construction
d'une nouvelle réforme des retraites
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
parce qu'il s'agit de leur retraite
celle tous les français sans exclusive
cette réforme doit être également la
leur elle doit se faire avec eux et pas
contre eux ou même sans eux
c'est pourquoi chers collègues que
j'apporterai mon soutien à cette réforme
référendaire
c'est beaucoup
la parole est à madame la présidente
nicole borvo cohen seat pour le groupe
crc spg
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre cher collègue monsieur le
ministre vous voulez rester sourd à la
revendication sociale qui monte dans ce
pays contre votre réforme et vous
devenez d'en faire la démonstration
il faut bien le dire assez caricatural
dans le troisième discours que nous vous
nous avez tenu aujourd'hui même vous
n'avez cessé depuis un mois de tenter de
minimiser les journées d'action et de
manifestations organisée par les
confédérations syndicales est largement
suivie par les salariés et les citoyens
qui les approuvent à plus de 70% le même
pourcentage désapprouvant votre réforme
des retraites
certes vous n'en n'êtes pas à votre coup
d'essai déjà à l'occasion du changement
de statut de la poste
antichambre de sa privatisation la
privatisation de gdf le bouclier fiscal
vous avez ignoré la contestation
populaire
même vos échecs électoraux ne semble pas
émouvoir nous l'avons bien compris vous
êtes en mission mettre en oeuvre le
programme des marchés financiers c'est à
dire laquelle
c'est à dire la casse systématique du
pacte social issu de la résistance qui
unit notre communauté nationale
et pour ce faire vous vous employez à
diviser notre peuple
vous et votre gouvernement et le
président de la république vous vous
employez à diviser notre peuple à faire
peur a stigmatisé des catégories
sociales à faire de ce étrangers des
boucs émissaires à substituer à la
question sociale l'ordre public
pour autant vous vous êtes appuyé
jusqu'ici sur le programme du candidat
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 validé par le
suffrage universel lors de son élection
il est vrai que le candidat sarkozy
n'avait caché ni ses objectifs ultra
libéraux ni ses affinités pour les
habitués du fouquet's mais il avait dit
aussi qu'il était le candidat mais il
avait dit aussi qu'il était le candidat
du pouvoir d'achat de la revalorisation
du travail
cela vous n'en parlez guerre tant les
résultats en sont loin
et le discours oubliée mais revenons aux
retraites
l'argument du programme présidentiel
n'est plus de mise aujourd'hui et pour
cause d'ailleurs vous ne l'avez pas
évoqué puisque nicolas sarkozy déclaré à
la presse en janvier 2007 le droit à la
retraite à 60 ans doit demeurer de même
que les 35 heures continueront d'être la
durée hebdomadaire du temps de travail
pourtant en 2007 aussi laurence parisot
dans le petit bréviaire du medef que
d'autres ont cité qui s'appelle besoin
d'air je vous le recommande parce qu'il
ya tout le programme du gouvernement
dedans dévoilée elle qu'elle était ce
programme pour l concernant les
retraites l'abaissement de l'âge de la
retraite de 65 à 60 ans en 1982 était
une erreur historique
évidemment madame parisot ne connaît pas
le suffrage universel semble-t-il le
président alors fait mine de résister il
disait elle a le droit de dire cela mais
moi je dis que je ne le ferai pas pour
un certain nombre de raisons la première
c'est que je n'en ai pas parlé pendant
ma campagne présidentielle
ce n'est pas un engagement que j'ai pris
devant les français et je n'ai pas
mandat pour le faire et ajouté t-il
ajouté t-il cela compte vous savez pour
moi
le mandat du peuple je crois comprendre
à l'évidence vous avez bien du mal à
vous réclamez du programme présidentiel
vous avez bien du mal à vous réclamez
d'un quelconque mandat du peuple
vous ne pouvez vous réclamez vous ne
pouvez vous réclamez que d'un seul
mandat celui du medef
là les choses sont claires
d'ailleurs madame parisot récemment
c'était sur son blog je crois se targuer
je la cite d'avoir avec son livre
toujours le même besoin d'air imposer le
débat économique dans la campagne
présidentielle et d'être à l'origine de
décisions économiques majeures prises
par le gouvernement
lesquels la réduction de l'is f pas pour
investissement dans une pme
le renforcement du crédit impôt
recherche
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle ou
encore c'est moi qu'ils ajoutent parce
que c'était dans le petit livre la
suppression de la clause de compétence
générale des collectivités territoriales
que le gouvernement veut absolument
faire voter donc vous voyez vous êtes en
phase totale avec le medef ça c'est sûr
mais mais mais non mais je n'invente
rien chers collègues je n'invente rien
mais du coup le peuple est donc fondée à
vous demander des comptes
alors qu'est-ce que vous évoquez pour
justifier aujourd'hui cette réforme la
vôtre qui n'étaient pas prévus par le
programme quinquennal du président de la
république
l'évolution démographique elle était
prévue bien avant 2007 et vous disiez
l'avoir résolu en 2003 jusqu'en 2018
2020 votre argument choc
c'est sûr c'est la crise il ya plus
d'argent
parlons-en et soyons précis la crise
c'est celle du capitalisme financier
c'est le résultat de la folie
spéculative de la déconnexion entre la
finance et l'économie réelle qui a mis
le monde au bord du gouffre vous avez
volé au secours des incendiaires les
banques les financiers les actionnaires
en 2009 à coups de milliards ou leur
avait ouvert un crédit de 360 milliards
d'euros sans contrepartie
pourtant le président de la république
toujours lui jamais avare de paroles se
faisait fort de moraliser le capitalisme
dans le monde
en france les résultats ont été rapides
les banques se portent à merveille les
bénéfices et par exemple de la bnp
paribas en 2009 a bondi de 93% et les
entreprises du cac 40 ont dégagé près de
50 milliards d'euros de profits les
jetons de présence des membres des
conseils d'administration de ces
entreprises du cac 40 ont progressé de
18% en 2009 ne viendront pas d'apprendre
que le directeur général de carrefour
grand employeur carrefour grands
employeurs de femmes précaires à temps
partiel et aux salaires de misère qui
auront des retraites honteuse
celui ci va partir après trois ans de
bons et loyaux services aux actionnaires
avec une retraite de cinq cent mille
euros par an
sur les 45 milliards d'euros de votre
plan retraite
plan retraite vous prévoyez d'en
prélever deux petits milliards sur les
revenus du capital
croyez vous que nos concitoyens sont
aveugles et sourds ne croyez vous pas
qu'il serait juste un terme que vous
aimez bien vous nous l'avez sorti
plusieurs fois de leur demander leur
avis sur votre réforme
d'autant que des projets alternatifs
contrairement à ce que vous dites
existent ils procèdent c'est évident ils
procèdent c'est évident deux conceptions
différentes et de modes de financement
différent aussi
pour notre part nous considérons que la
retraite à 60 ans est un droit et un
acquis d'années de luttes démocratiques
aux meilleurs
c'est le droit de bénéficier d'une
retraite en bonne santé
je vous rappelle que l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé d'un ouvrier et de 69 ans
non la retraite c'est pouvoir avoir une
retraite en bonne santé
voilà pour notre part nous considérons
que l'emploi est un enjeu majeur vous
n'en parlez jamais créer cent mille
emplois c'est 1,5 milliard d'euros de
recettes pour la protection sociale
ce doit être la priorité la priorité
pour les jeunes dont le taux de chômage
et de précarité est aujourd'hui
insupportable à la différence de
l'allemagne
à la différence de l'espagne il y à des
jeunes en france il y à renouvellement
des générations
mais nos jeunes sont insupportablement
en chômage voilà la réalité
pour notre part nous proposons de
financer la retraite à 60 ans à taux
plein en faisant cotiser les revenus du
capital au même taux que les salaires
c'est pas du luxe au même taux que les
salaires en modulant nous proposons de
moduler les cotisations patronales en
fonction de l'emploi parce que jusqu'à
présent vous n'avez guère réussi à coude
exonérations à faire créer des emplois
par les entreprises en supprimant les
exonérations de cotisations patronales
inefficace pour l'emploi d'autres
propositions ont été faites y a pas que
nous qui en faisons d'autres ont été
faites et déjà d'abord les organisations
syndicales
parlons-en encore un oubli des promesses
de nicolas sarkozy le dialogue social il
s'en voulait le champion sur les
retraites
il n'en est plus question certes vous
avez rencontré les organisations
syndicales mais comme elle était opposée
à votre projet et unis vous n'avez
ouvert aucune négociation
aujourd'hui les organisations syndicales
soutenu par la grande majorité de nos
concitoyens continuent avec
détermination et dans l'union
de vous demander de véritables
négociations sur une réforme de
retraites juste et efficace ce qui
signifie prendre en considération les
propositions qu'elles font c'est ça les
négociations avec des partenaires
sociaux prendre en condition les
propositions qu'elles font
l'interruption brutale du débat à
l'assemblée nationale
l'urgence déclarée sur ce texte de votre
fébrilité ne sont pas les bonnes
réponses
d'ailleurs on vous croirait engagés dans
une partie de poker menteur
vous parlez de possibles améliorations
du texte sans préciser quels sont vos
propres amendements
avez vous un clar faiblesse n'accroisse
encore le mécontentement
ou croyez-vous au contraire décourager
la future mobilisation du 12 octobre
en les annonçant par exemple lowe's je
crains que vous n'entendiez pas bien ce
que disent les organisations syndicales
les salariés et la grande majorité du
peuple
cette réforme cette réforme votre
réforme n'est pas la bonne il faut
retirer ce projet est ré ouvrir une
véritable négociation
prenant en compte des propositions
alternatives fait principalement par les
représentants des salariés
voilà pourquoi nous vous demandons et
demandons au président de la république
de consulter le peuple lui même est un
ministre ne peut ignorer que même si le
référendum prévu par la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 n'est pas
encore applicable à cause de qui de vous
qui ne voulez pas le faire appliquer et
bien le président de la république mais
absolument
le président de la république avec
l'article 11 actuelle que vous le lire
si vous voulez mais je vous en dispense
parce que je suis très certes absolument
sûr que vous le connaissez peut
consulter le peuple sur un sujet qui
touche aux questions économiques et
sociales qui concerne l'ensemble du pays
il faut demander au peuple s'il veut de
votre réforme et s'ils répondent non et
bien vous serez dans l'obligation vous
et votre gouvernement de remettre sur le
tapis une véritable négociation avec les
partenaires
sociaux sur un projet alternatif
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
invite comme nos collègues socialistes à
voter cette motion
la retraite y est content
la parole la parole est un monsieur
nicolas à bouhours l'union centriste et
pour 16 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
souscrivons pas la plupart des motifs
invoqués en soutien la présente motion
référendaire et encore moins à ces
conclusions
il nous est expliqué que cette réforme
serait engagée sans mandat du peuple
cela sous prétexte que le président de
la république se serait engagé à
maintenir l'âge d'ouverture des droits à
60 ans drôle d'argument en démocratie
parlementaire
la première règle et s'écouter
écoutez écoutez hier vous avez joué au
foulard aujourd'hui vous jouez au loup
il reste la marelle et les pays riches
de by thé sont arrêtés donc je vous dis
que c'est un drôle d'argument en
démocratie parlementaire il n'y a pas de
mandat impératif
le mandat donné par le peuple et celui
qu'il a voulu donner à l'actuelle
majorité majorité qui aujourd'hui
contrairement à d'autres prend ses
responsabilités en tâchant de sauver la
répartition
le peuple français est aujourd'hui bien
en position de tranchée par le biais de
sa représentation nationale
quant à l'opinion publique elle n'est
pas si hostile à la réforme que vous
voulez bien le dire
chacun bien conscience de la nécessité
d'agir
le déplacement de la borne d'âge
d'ouverture des droits
la principale mesure du texte darier
hentsch quand elle est en phase avec
tout ce qu'on fait nos partenaires
européens et avec l'accroissement de
l'espérance de vie
aa le fait et évite aux enchères est
d'accord et des missions et israël sont
liés aux minorités et ce n'est pas
rentable
moi je dis non
il en existe oui et vous
on parle économie forme je suis 100 et
par le point où les comptes notionnels
il nous faut dès maintenant et à l'orée
d'une tête réforme un suivi concertée
paraît-il qui s'ouvrait et ici comme un
vieux débat d'une retraite sur deux un
peu l'outil idéal consultation est ici
on te connais tu avais aurait on le
croirait au lit alors admettons que nous
que nous devons avoir et celle du
parlement pour des parlementaires
demandent un référendum sur une telle
question pourrait même s'apparenter à
une démission s'il ne nous appartient
pas de nous prononcer sur les retraites